so let's take another hypothetical and
let's say one writer has a script about
a girl that's in high school and she
wants to make sure that she's the one
that's voted for prom queen and she's
kind of has a rival that's similar level
as she and then there's another script
where it's about a foreign exchange
student who's a little out there and
maybe she's an introverted writer and
it's not as you know she's maybe not on
that same sort of high school level
which one would you suggest that someone
I mean it seems like the answer is
obvious but why why why the high school
prom queen I think I mean I'm not
attacking you but I'm just curious why
do people want to see these very sort of
cookie cutter films when there's a more
of a flavorful range out there in
general it's because we if you're going
to a grocery store you're purchasing a
product you know what you're getting in
the end and that's kind of the idea when
you're watching a movie when you're
gonna transact on a movie whether you're
buying a ticket
getting a copy on Amazon or some other
you know transactional VOD service
you're looking for an emotional
experience and you want one that's best
gonna cater to the one you're looking to
feel now actually I would offer a third
option in this which would be instead of
the high school I would take the high
school script over the foreign exchange
one hands down but I would take it and
we would probably rebrand that and make
a junior high and make it more focused
on a tween girl audience knowing that 9
to 12 year old girls are the most likely
audience to be renting movies and buying
movies on something like iTunes Amazon
or other platforms and I would see
bigger numbers doing that and I'd make a
really nice pink poster see this is how
we're talking it's you come in with an
idea and then we target an audience we
know we need to hit and then we we
create a concept around that and I can
already see the key art in my head and I
would go talk to my team's about doing
that I know how much money we can make
internationally with a movie like that
and we would go then have either take
that writer and have them rewrite it or
we go hire a writer we've had experience
with to write the movie we now just
create it in two minutes and keeping
this film
who's the protagonist like what's her
makeup and who's the who's the
character and who's the guy they're
fighting in a tween girl movie the
protagonist is a young girl who is not
the most popular girl in school
she needs to be you know fun average but
you know like has all the potential to
be great but she just doesn't see it in
herself yet and there's always that cool
girl who has all the cool friends and
who makes fun of her and things are
always happening that are you know it's
never going her way she always makes a
fool of herself in front of the boy she
likes etc and then she has some kind of
secret characteristic a magical ability
maybe somebody comes to her and she's
suddenly granted a day where she could
make dreams come true maybe maybe some
element like that that it's a special
skill that only she has she she tries to
use it to become like the girl she
thinks she wants to become which is the
antagonist and ultimately realizes that
she doesn't want to become like that
person she's far better than her and can
become something completely different
and at the end of course she just
realizes it's herself she's just
evolving bla bla bla bla bla but that's
the story that just means a lot to them
and who's the guy that they're they're
both rivals for the guy is usually it
differs there can be the really cute boy
that all the girls like and that our
protagonist just somehow has a chance
encounter to meet with and has some kind
of random reason to be in communication
with him they're neighbors
he's he's trying to use her for
something and then realize he has
feelings for her through the process or
he's just kind of the arrogant guy that
all the girls like and there's actually
kind of the goofy friend guy who does
live next door whom everyone overlooks
and then he Ben our protagonist realizes
that she this guy's actually fantastic
and he's like the hero at the end and
they they get to go off and make
everyone else jealous I'd rent this
movie yes yeah you'd rent it I wonder a
lot of young girls would rent it and
they would watch it over and over and
over again and we have a lot of movies
like that here and it's amazing to me
how many middle-aged women come in
middle-aged men - and they go my
daughter just loves this can I get a
free screen or copy just so I can like
paying for it on red box or something
else so they're so that they is through
identification that that's what's
getting them admit to live out that
fantasy and you know most people are
going to be that girl in junior high or
or that guy friend that was maybe
overlooked and so they identify yeah and
here's what's interesting about it the
young girls younger girls want to see
the junior high girl because she's a
little bit older than what she is or
she's very close in age girls at that
age are very obviously self-conscious
they want to know what their what other
girls are doing if they're behind so
that they can get ahead boys at that age
are also very curious and they boys that
age secretly really like those movies
too they like the really feel-good
movies they understand these experiences
and they're they get just as emotionally
drawn into them as well boys at that age
will not identify with a male version of
that the boys at that age would act
would rather go see an action film or
something like that if they want the
male skew so they're not going to go
after like a male version of that
younger boys will like ages 6 to 11 but
like a tween aged boy doesn't want to
see teenage boys he'll watch a tween age
girl film and lied to his friends that
he did or he wants to go see a rated-r
action film and that's actually where
the other big genre is the aging male
comeback film
you